il est mignon il s'appelle Bud et grâce
à lui un meurtrier s'est fait arrêter il
y a zéro blague en 2015 Martin durable
est retrouvé mort à son domicile criblé
de 5 balles dans le corps le perroquet
lui va bien rassurez-vous sa femme gléna
était aussi présente lors de l'attaque
sauf qu'elle s'en sort et elle est juste
blessée à l'oreille en revanche elle est
tellement choquée de ce qui vient de se
passer qu'elle ne se souvient de rien
pour la police c'est une intrusion qui a
mal tourné pod était présent dans la
pièce lors du meurtre de Martin bonne
c'est un perroquet et donc il est
capable de reproduire tous les sons
qu'il a entendu cette nuit là lors de
l'attaque ça devient intéressant parce
que les sons qui reproduit ressemblent à
une dispute conjugale
et ce qui est ouf c'est que Bud il va
même jusqu'à reproduire le sifflement
des balles
finalité de l'histoire grâce à Bud et
d'autres preuves concordantes évidemment
gléna se fait arrêter par la police elle
se fait interroger et elle craque c'est
bien elle qui a tiré sur son mari bravo
Bob t'es un sacré beau gosse et
maintenant vous voulez tout simplement